γιατί κάνες γιατί μαρος να βάλεις υμάρχος ε σκέφτηκε το θα εψιφιζω θεωρώ ότι ένα
πο τυ πιο αυτερος κριτες πάντα ήτα ο παπάμου πποτέ ενα θα σου π και
που θέει να ακούσεις να σου πίτιο που έθλ να ακούσεις για να σε κάνει
καλύπτερο χτυπήματα γάτω από τη μέση ναιδέχτηκ νο αντρέα στην πολιτική δεκτησκτιγμα τα κάτο που
μέσγίνεται δυστυχώς το κλίμα πλέον είναιτα λον και πιο το ψηκομενούν τα μεθα κινοκή δικίωση
ο κόσμος δηψάια ίεμα κόσμος που είαιλαλίζαλε να ξρουνανα έχει απόψηετεν ίμεκαλος δήμαρχοτς σεβαστών είσαι
πολιτικό πρόσεπο πράτε έχεσει την κριτική δ έχουμε το είνειε καλ δήμαρχος το το μίσως
ούλο και ούτι έτι να πουότον το έσκιν πούλα μετα κυπρια άην πηγάζει ιαςούμε αι
που τουκάμανα ποι όται είναι μεκαλούς δήμαρχος ττοέχει πανωθέλα πο ότι το ότιότερο πράγμα που
άκουσες για των αντρέα βύρα που που έ που εν το αφηκες πστο τραπέδ σκέφτεσμοτοπιον
ίτ δεν ξαντιλα τιμέα πο ευρέτηκε στο ήμαξ και ούλι πρόμεούλ είμαστε κλέφτες πιαντα από
του ισρατινούς έπιαντα πολιβανέζ ποιαντα πό τον κοστί είνα παντα πό το γιανί τηλαβών νες
υμαθαίνει και ογίσμονε το πράγμα αλλά δυστυχώς ένιμε ο όσον κολοκασόφιλλών πρέπει για πολιτικοςγιατί ντέξεις
κάποιος σημιών και μετά πραθι λίον κορο κασόφίλ του λά δεν είσαι περνεί σταμαζίσσουν και
νεν καλοτο το πράτρόεσκαι ν έχει να πράνα που θέρο αλλάξυ εντούτο να είνω παραπάνω
κολοκασόφιλο να μεταλαμβανοκψει νράθα σε ποψηστοωιοτόπρ αλλάειπαραλαμβάννω ότιαντιλαμβάνε σε δήμααρχος να πας έτσι α που
γίνεται άρα εναι ευκολα πργματα ούτε ευκολές αποφάσεις ούτε πράματα τα οποία τάξε έναι τι
εχάσεις φίλοςάξι πραγματικούς θείους όλι κραγματιύς φρο α έχασα αλλά σίγουρα ανταξι κάποια παράπονα κάποια
έτσι ότι μάπρε να κάνει σ τον πράγμα και ενώ θέλα πό ότι να πό
ότε έχα στα πραγματικός φοσεν έχασα καιτο ο που έρομ ότι ίληο ίδη που τον
κιρό που εμωρών η παραπάνω